bienvenue dans votre auto qui somment du
soir bonsoir
avec nous ce soir
trois terrains de choix d'un robot gens
me
concerne ça va aujourd'hui je suis très
angoissé à l'idée de rencontrer celui
dont on ne devrait pas prononcer le nom
voldemort non homogène
avec jean mus soir marc olivier fogiel
salut marcos a lui tiré alors dix ans
qui reçoit fogiel c'est pas une émission
de télé c'est via le tas il ya un truc
comme ça c'est historique en tout cas je
suis très heureux que vous soyez la main
mais je suis super content d'être là -
que gaspard à 2 - médias
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
n ont pas
je voulais pas déranger je viens juste
un peu au début
voir qui est qu'est-ce que je pourrais
dire de
de dégueulasse tout à l'heure
alors bon fogiel ah oui c'est maintenant
le salat j'ai vu le divan super vraiment
extraordinaire c'est vachement
apparemment le prochain client donc ccc
vous savez ok on vous avait déjà fait
luchini c'est en une séance vous l'avez
guéri il
a neuf ans derrière la bcc là ou que
votre spécialité c'est vraiment de vous
tromper de vocation
[Applaudissements]
matge pas de blague pas j'ai rien je
sais pas ce que dira par contre vous
donc j'ai entendu votre histoire de pied
un peu particulière la jeu j'espère que
vous nous ferez une démonstration toupie
parce que c'est
non pour pourquoi pas
why not et j'ai entendu la filoche qui
vient tout à leur ouïe le pays n'a pas
déjà assez pleuré
non parce que j'ai rien contre lui mais
va encore venir puisque vous savez ce
que c'est que de vivre avec eux le
savent et bah non c'est pas on n'a pas
envie en fait
il a cette voie d'équidés qui pare
d'argent et commence à bourg-des-comptes
vie ne lui dirai qu'il faut une liste
positive des missiles bah non c'est
surtout la preuve que même le ministre
se trouvait que l'état demandé trop
d'impôts c'est tout bon à part ça beau
je reviens tout à l'heure pour le reste
et notamment
voir l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens le robot s'appelle jean me et
le groupe et gréement de fortune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on passe maintenant à notre tt ou de
la semaine
[Musique]
marc olivier fogiel re bonsoir bonsoir
chers
et non pas re bonsoir
c'est fini tout ça vous êtes ici ce soir
pour une émission exceptionnelle marco
réalisée sous l'égide de l'onu puisque
ça y est après 15 en guerre nous sommes
réconciliés miss france avait raison la
paix dans le monde c'est possible
j'avais pensé à un lâcher de colombes
faut dire qu'avant de nous faire la
guerre on est et on était super pote
vous avez été le seul journaliste
accepté chez moi en normandie c'était
pour un pilote pour canal+ cette chaîne
c'était la première fois que je faisais
de la télé mon cobaye et et hiriart 10
et voilà on regarde comme ça
[Musique]
les gens pensent que je passe tous venez
aux bains douches de 8 heures du matin
des mannequins que la tête dans la
farine tant mieux s'ils pensent que je
peux diriger deux émissions de journaux
en
endormant deux heures par nuit c'est
génial c'est un surhomme
[Musique]
si tu es obligé d'en faire de la télé
qui finit par faire la météo qu'au bout
d'un moment un jour tu te fais dire hey
tu as besoin de payer son loyer doit
faire la météo j'ai plein d'amis à la
télé aujourd'hui kif qui font la musique
go
[Applaudissements]
vite passé d'être celui qui demande aux
starlettes si elles sont clitoridiennes
vaginal ou anal je les fais longtemps
maintenant j'ai envie de faire ça vous
amuse ça m'amuse moi je sais maintenant
[Musique]
si j'étais pas mégalo ce serait toujours
en train de gratter pour des marchands
de lessive
cm mégalomanie qui m'a sauvé
et voilà
le plus mal habillé
quelques mois la prochaine pandémie
votre famille à la maison oui il faut
beaucoup de pièces chez moi mais c'est
un grand château une grande famille
maintenant on se passera plus jamais
c'est promis juré alors en fait toute
l'histoire avait commencé à l'époque de
de tout le monde en parle vous aviez
fait une émission qui s'appelait on ne
peut pas plaire à tout le monde tout le
monde en parle d'eux dans ça s'appelait
mon truc quand c'était la même chose
or voilà donc je m'étais énervé contre
vous et j'aurais dû avoir le courage à
l'époque de m'énerver contre le le
patron de france télévisions et voilà je
m'en suis pris à vous ça a duré très
longtemps maintenant c'est fini on
s'aime on sait maintenant et maintenant
mesdames messieurs un big up pour la
paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors marc ollivier vu qu'on a fait la
paix maintenant vous ne serez pas étonné
que je vous fasse une interview michel
drucker
[Musique]
formidable là messieurs marc ollivier
enfin jacques olivier fogiel ça fait
quoi d'avoir révolutionné la télévision
avec un ton nouveau ça fait chier
thierry ardisson
sinon vous aimez les chiens marc-olivier
les rockets
bien du site du bart ans toujours aussi
belle ouais les jours aussi jeune
alors sarkozy c'est vraiment un homme
politique formidable c'est lui qu'il
faut pour la france je trouvais pas ou
pour abou dhabi aussi françois hollande
c'est vraiment un homme politique
formidable c'est lui qu'il faut pour la
france
c'est l'interview drucker la mort de
demis roussos j'en ai pensé quoi que ça
allait faire quelques galas en plus pour
mon copain dave
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui maintenant que vous êtes
réconcilier pour toujours marco tu peux
nous parler de ton projet d'émission il
et vendredi à 19 heures sur canal
les coucous des martiens
il faut comme l'énervé on a mis 15 ans
pour
twitter
quand on regarde votre vie on voit que
votre père et était dentiste il avait
des clients starbucks pernand il soigné
par exemple philippe labro alors vous
aussi vous fait asseoir des stars dans
un fauteuil en leur disant que tout va
bien se passer j'espère qu'il leur fait
moins mal que le dentiste peut faire mal
d'ailleurs vous vous arrachez des
confidences lui c'était des molaires
alors c'est votre père qui vous a fait
entrer rtl vous ai commencé très bas au
jeu au début vous jouiez de la trompette
bon
sérieusement au début de découpe y ait
des dépêches la nuit même avant ça
puisque j'y allais le matin avant
d'aller au lit c'est le soir pendant
sortant et ensuite la nuit j'ai coupé
les dépêches puisque cela m'était comme
j'ai pu mais c'était super c on
apprenait son métier là au milieu de
cette rédaction et c'était génial alors
le plus incroyable c'est qu'en préparant
cette unité a view j'ai découvert que
nous avions énormément de points communs
ah ouais d'abord j'étais un enfant
sérieux votre soeur a dit c'était un
adulte dans un corps d'enfant oui
j'étais plutôt pas très insouciant
pendant les vacances du travail et j'ai
fait plein de petits métiers j'ai bossé
dans les bars j'étais serveurs j'étais
préparateur en pharmacie je faisais très
bien les suppôts s'être enfin c'est vrai
il fallait couler les suppôts
deuxième point commun nous avions tous
les deux des problèmes de surpoids et
voilà on était gros quand on était petit
ah ouais très bon vous avez été aux
belges jusqu'à l'âge de 14 15 ans était
bien ouais bien gros dispensés de sport
voilà moi aussi troisième point commun
l'émotivité ouais je rosissait cette
voie là ouais j'avais la sueur froide
j'avais les mains moites espèce de
timidité maladive qu'on a un peu soigné
à la téloche l'un et l'autre sans doute
le quatrième point c'est le désir de
célébrité 1 à l'âge de 7 ans vous alliez
sur les champs elysées avec votre soeur
avec un magnétophone pour interviewer
les gens comme incroyable ça non mais
serait fait refaire ça en fait je rêvais
d'être reporter moi quand je la hais les
gamins et c'est vrai que c'était un peu
en quête de notoriété il avait ce désir
moi par exemple j'avais écrit un livre à
la main et dans la préface du j'avais 10
ans dans la préface du livre je m'auto
interview
[Rires]
et la dernière est bien là et célébrités
s'amuser en dit est vrai en fait je me
suis rendu compte assez vite que c'est
pas ça qui m'intéressait c'était pas
déplaisant bien au contraire mais je me
suis pas épanoui dans l'idée qu'on me
reconnaisse non alors on a un autre
point commun c'est qu'on est prêt à
bosser quoi manque de confiance en soi
qui fait qu'on bosse je fais combien à
rennes m'a finalement
[Applaudissements]
alors
dernier point
nous préférons être jugé sur une fausse
image plutôt que nous dévoiler ça c'est
vrai de sel moi je savais un peu tu es
un peu égal qu'on puisse commenter mon
image médiatique appartement où je me
cache derrière ça me va très bien ça
sauf que maintenant avec la j'aurais
peut-être un peu de maturité jeu pour à
l'expérience je suis plus à l'aise pour
parler plus facilement de moi comme vous
dire alors vous êtes ici ce soir pour
nous parler du divan votre nouvelle
émission sur france 3 alors quand vous
avez cherché un concept ou votre retour
à la télé je vais d'abord penser à ça
mais bon c'était un peu trop ensuite
vous êtes dit et si l'invité était mort
ouais absolument un et je me suis mêlé
screen ardisson avait pas fait ça déjà
avant l'interview sert qu à l affaire de
saga josy pourvu que j'évite donc j'ai
changé donc finalement vous avez choisi
le divan librement inspiré du fameux
divan d'henri chapier dont le concept
est très simple très fort transformer
l'interview en une séance de
psychanalyse on regarde ce que des
chapitres et
venait d'avoir 40 ans vous l'avouer une
personne n'avoue jamais son âge vous
vous l'avouer parce que vous le faites
pas bien sûr mais enfin il ya vingt ans
qu'on s'obstine à vouloir prouver que
quelque part je ne sais pas peut-être
dans une autre vie vous étiez un homme
mais c'est un peu vous qui avez initié
tout ça non pourquoi dans une autre vie
oui j'ai été un homme en effet qu'est ce
que j'ai
quelqu'un en italie une fois par un
voyant un médium m'a dit que j'avais été
un soldat je crois italien au xiiie
siècle et pillages avaient été une
esclave égyptienne un vrai bon temps
plusieurs vies mais si on y croit dans
cette vie j'ai toujours été une femme et
j'aurais aimé être nov voilà ça c'est le
livre d'henry chapier et maintenant on
regarde le divan de marc dufau jeunes
bat toujours amusé sept ballons c'est
comme serait sur les gens parce que mais
je le pense vraiment que je veux dire
c'est pas il ya des gens qui ne le
disent pas moi je le dis bon je sais pas
si c'est intelligent mais j'arrive pas à
pas le dire des voix mais le problème
c'est pas tellement de le dire c'est le
penser mais je pense que je dis
évidemment il avait sur la cible
évidemment que je pense que je dis oui
vous avez bien mais ça vous le pensez il
ya quoi de le coter faire le buzz mais
il ya aussi il n'ya pas faire le buzz je
dire j'ai pas besoin de ça pour faire le
buzz quand même ça va enfin julien mon
émission marche bien je passe je suis
pas très pour faire le buzz non je le
pense quoi c'est tout puis j'ai un côté
cruel c'est vrai quand j'étais petit
jard h et les ailes des mouches et c'est
vrai que j'ai toujours un côté un peu
cruel
[Applaudissements]
alors ma peau ouais il ya ya quoi comme
différence alors expliquez nous déjà
l'émission est beaucoup plus longue
l'émission d'henri c'était une
discussion débridé pendant 26 minutes
intéressantes là on sillonne dans le
parcours de vie d'un invité de façon
chapitre est celle qu'on a fait ensemble
au tir et elle fait 70 minutes et cette
durée je crois permet à l'invité de
montrer peut-être plus d'aspects de sa
personnalité on enregistrait la note qui
passe mardi il ya quelques jours quand
vous avez sorti vous m'avez dit voilà la
reddition c'est moi à oui j'ai vraiment
dit ça en tout cas vous avez été
extrêmement généreux dans ce que vous
avez livré de vous même dans les camps
se sont super
alors
est-ce que vous n'aviez pas peur car ils
chapuis vous accuse de plagiat c'est
cette fois ci je l'avais appelé à avoir
et il m'avait donné une forme de blanc
sans danger un casting de rêve je parle
pas de moi mais il ya un an' hidalgo
ouais karl lagerfeld ouais luc besson
josiane balasko mêlant chant isabelle
adjani lille k way dupond-moretti pas
mal de voilà des dépannages déjà à la
forte personnalité pour lesquelles j'ai
une grande curiosité j'aimerais beaucoup
invités mate un de ces jours ah ben oui
bah tu devrais y aller j'irai nôtres
et bien y'a un truc et c'est très
difficile
la personne devant toi je t'ai derrière
et s'étaient livrés à toi mme sarabi
contrairement à ce qu'ils faisaient
avant ils laissent des blancs et laisse
cette fois ci a passé déjà mis sur les
divans ça doit te faire tout drôle de te
retrouver dans le rôle du psychanalyste
et non en fait je suis pas vraiment
nombre de psychanalystes parce que j'ai
trop de respect pour justement le
travail de thérapie moi je me suis
allongé 18 ans et là c'est vraiment un
rôle plutôt de journalistes mais c'est
vrai que le clin d'oeil m'amuse
vous allez en faire vraiment ouais c'est
une collection de 20 numéros en fait
c'est une espèce de parenthèse dans ma
vie professionnelle pour l'instant on
verra bien après pourquoi parce que je
suis heureux dans ce que je fais à la
radio depuis maintenant quelques années
c'est ce qui aujourd'hui occupent mais
ça prend beaucoup de temps ça va
beaucoup d'énergie j'ai une vie de
famille que je veux surtout pas
sacrifier donc ça laisse peu d'espacé
pour faire autre chose là j'ai trouvé
des petits espaces pour faire ça on
verra après là on s'est tous les mardis
donc en deuxième partie de soirée sur
france 3 et leurs 23 heures donc voilà
ça permet justement de ne pas être
efficace doit chercher en permanence qui
se passe un truc toutes les cinq
secondes j'ai regardé luchini j'ai
trouvé ça bien ouais ouais pourtant
j'aime pas luchini
c'est pas vrai
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux